ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz mit
groupe mutuel versicherungen blut geil
seit 20 jahren für sie da von vier
paaren handeln dieser geschichten von
menschen die sich dazu entschieden haben
freud und leid miteinander zu teilen von
liebenden die darauf hoffen dass ihr
gemeinsames glück möglichst für immer
anhalten möge und die doch wissen dass
misstöne dazu gehören können selbst in
der himmel voller geigen ist
[Musik]
als bräutigam am altar zu stehen und auf
die braut zu warten millionen von
männern haben das schon erlebt und doch
ist dieser augenblick immer wieder aufs
neue einmalig unbeschreiblich treten
petkovic glück ist spürbar als er
endlich aldiana im brautkleid vor sich
sieht
[Musik]
in der letzten sendung haben sich
aldiana und treten auf dem
zivilstandsamt trauen lassen
die ehe von christian reich und bier
nidda del carmen wurde in der
dominikanischen republik und in der
schweiz anerkannt
auch manuela und christian hilfiger
besiegelten ihrer liebe und andrea
buchecker und olic der ball den kniefall
vor der ehe
[Musik]
in einer serbisch orthodoxen
hochzeitsfeier wird dem brautpaar sehr
früh die frage aller fragen gestellt
außerdem müssen beide verneinen dass sie
jemand anderem versprochen sind
[Applaus]
erst jetzt nachdem das geklärt ist
verbindet der pfarrer das brautpaar
symbolisch miteinander
[Musik]
als symbol dafür dass die liebe regieren
soll erhalten zuerst treten und dann
auch aldiana im namen des vaters des
sohnes und des heiligen geistes die
krone aufgesetzt
[Musik]
noch vor zwei tagen lag sreten mit einer
schweren erkältung danieder
seither ist seine angst große könnte den
gottesdienst nicht durchstehen
[Musik]
doch seine bedenken sind unnötig dank
sei der orthodoxen liturgie die vorsieht
dass das brautpaar nicht nur still da
stehen muss dreimal umkreisen aldiana
und treten nach dem segen den tisch
[Musik]
o
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der dominikanischen küstenstadt
puerto plata soll es hat er ebenfalls
feierlich zu gehen wie ein baby da ist
schon seit den frühen morgenstunden
daran ihr haus für das hochzeitsfest mit
christian reich zu schmücken schwestern
freundinnen söhne alle helfen mit
nur der bräutigam der nimmt das
erstaunlich gelassen
schließlich hat christian große
erfahrung mit hochzeiten vorgehen wie
nie da war er schon mit vier anderen
frauen verheiratet scheinheirat wurde er
in der schweiz genannt darunter leidet
nun bienvenido denn die behörden wollen
dem paar nicht so recht glauben dass es
sie mit der liebe wirklich ernst ist
[Musik]
ich sollte
zu tun
ottawa kanada
für aldiana und treten hat das abenteuer
er begonnen
[Musik]
mit gottes segen und den besten wünschen
aller anwesenden betreten sie ihr ganz
persönliches neuland
in puerto plata sind die zimmer
geschmückt und die blumenmädchen park
und auch bieten wir nie da findet nun
zeit sich als braut schön machen zu
lassen
ich freue mich darauf wenn ich mich
christian zeigen kann
das ist bild machen aber meine schöne
frau gar nicht so einfach
ja weihnachten getankt und erleben
wer weiß was noch alles passiert wenn
das stört mich
[Musik]
die liebe hat auf dem lebensweg von
christian reich schon manche fußspuren
hinterlassen
doch auch beim erfahrenen heirat
erscheint die magie eines augenblicks zu
wirken wenn die braut ganz in weiß vor
ihm steht
[Musik]
okay okay
die stadt mit dem schönen moment der
gummihand die ganze familie mich alles
was sie zur kamera
und dann gibt es noch einen kleinen test
aber technisch in schwamendingen ist der
familiengottesdienst vorbei jetzt sind
die weltlichen rituale an der reihe
[Applaus]
zum ersten mal an diesem tag hat das
brautpaar einen moment für sich allein
und kann sich während der fahrt nach zug
zurücklehnen und das ist speziell für
jetzt auch öffentlich
na ja und sie nicht mit dem computer
doch das war mit denen es vereine und
den zoo der saal eröffnet
da war riesig hat gummisohle wollte
beginnen
[Musik]
wenn uli bärtschi nach vorne schaut
sieht er zwar das glück seiner liebe
doch von waidmannsheil keine spur
diese politik ist ein anderer
die rede der im homo sozial zwei stunden
zeit - ein name
der landwirt gehört der jagdgesellschaft
lütisburg an als so gern würde er heute
das reh erwischen dass er in seinem
revier vermutet
auf dem bauernhof der burgess ist
andreas mutter adelheid buchecker zu
besuch
[Musik]
als nach der 4
doch auch der sc noch und jemals für den
start des lebens wunderbar die heinz
christoph dahin und allianz sie
eigentlich wirklich um gottes willen
darlehen tragen orte und innovativ dass
der ueli hätten fallen müssen sich dem
turbo akzeptieren andreas
wer wie andrea einen landwirt heiratet
sagt auch ja zum leben auf dem bauernhof
in zukunft wie sie die erfahrung die sie
bisher an der uni st gallen sammeln
konnte auch für eigene projekte nutzen
betrieb aufbauen
den anfang macht die konfitüre die sie
unter anleitung der mutter erstmals
zubereitet später wollen uli und andrea
auch andere produkte direkt in ihrem
online hofladen anbieten sich das
vorpreschen der schweizer durchsetzen
der musiker erwiesen wenn jetzt 23 will
die einer- weltmeister
jetzt sitze ich mache sport damit die
große zuschlag aber einfach mit bewege
für einmal muss uhr li mit leeren händen
heimkehren
[Musik]
währenddessen ist die kleine feier im
innenhof von bmw nie das haus zu einem
ansehnlichen hochzeitsfest angewachsen
ganz wichtig wunderbar sein umfeld ist
für sie zum mitglied des special
aber meine hand gedrückt bevor lang
jetzt mit mehr getan als träger
männerklasse und dann holt sie galt doch
vorerst genießt christian reich heute
den großen tag denn schon bald wird er
in die schweiz zurückreisen
[Gelächter]
gegen abend beginnen sich die freunde
und nachbarn langsam zu verabschieden
[Gelächter]
daran kann steht und kritik verwaltung
kann ich nehme mit der hand von gaddafi
ruhig meinte ganztags richtfest und in
merligen über dem thunersee
während manuela und christian hilfiker
morgen heiraten in der ganzen vorfreude
quält manuela ein bisschen der gedanke
an den einmarsch im brautkleid
ihr vater wir sie zwischen den eng
stehenden banken zum altar führen
[Gelächter]
christian der als landschaftsgärtner
arbeitet kümmert sich liebevoll um den
blumenschmuck
was wäre für dich morgen das schlimmste
was passieren kann
[Gelächter]
das wäre schlimm
ich stehe auf meinem kleid du bist auch
allen schritt und stehst im unterrock
tor im unterrock stehst du dann das wäre
das schlimmste so führen münster
du musst warten bis ich sie dir schenken
[Musik]
petter solberg
ein bisschen besser
häufig der wirkung meiner tochter helfen
[Musik]
so haben wir besser platz aber ihr kleid
ist natürlich kunden weiter wird ein
bisschen schwierig werden nicht darauf
zu treten
ich habe es auch nicht sehen wir zwei
sind hier die armen leute
wir kennen uns nicht aus sondern alles
richtig machen haben nichts gesehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aldiana seitens großer tag war bisher
eine wahre märchen hochzeit
doch jetzt kommt beim bräutigam
plötzlich nervosität auf
er wolle man mehr verzögerung und zwar
heftig wehren heftig ja eigentlich hätte
dieser wäre etwas zu suchen wir
gedanklich und sich gegen einstellen
wir warten wir sind sechster
so brauche ich muss jetzt war da alles
organisiert haben
[Musik]
obwohl einzelne plätze an den tischen
noch nicht besetzt sind beschließt räten
mit dem offiziellen festprogramm zu
beginnen
[Musik]
ok
[Applaus]
zweitens vater radio lässt es sich nicht
nehmen die festgesellschaft zu begrüßen
und ein paar worte an die ganze familie
zu richten und sie auf liebe familie
liebe für die arbeitskollegen
es ist diese große ja dass sie so
zahlreich erschienen sind ist es somit
und jetzt per sofort das buffet eröffnet
[Applaus]
ganz soweit sind andrea und uli noch
nicht doch gleich nach der hochzeit
wollen sie ihren internet hochladen
vorantreiben nur fehlt noch das logo für
ihr kleines unternehmen wir da so
verschieden ich irgendwo macht auf die
augen paid by the c moll einfacher
vorbereiten mit dem staub dann auch und
den lehrgang fortlaufend was den kunden
erstellen des fisches es gibt immer den
möglichen politischen kurs machen oder
auch bereite nicht in fleisch direkt ab
hof ist es natürlich dass man hier denn
mal etwas infekte und vermarkter aber
startete am nachmittag um 4
nein wir werden jetzt einmal aber die
ideen ins doppel klingt ja wie viel
mit benzin und öko scharf und nun vom
bruderhof und vom wald und yahoo
ich bin total bescheiden aber wenn wir
jetzt soll diese bayern bringt und
irgendwie dono mit 2 stand 3 anja prehm
also die stadt voll dahinter und ich
sehe mich und sicher wir bringen die
samen für jedes bild muss ich meinen
also dass das sind ja so funktionieren
wie grimm die stein und der oder die
eine vorbei glaube jetzt lief sammelte
sie traf moritz malawi ist es auch mit
einer gruppe glasmaler habe man jetzt
als leise spielt ein mehrfach verstoßen
das fest ist aus die tafel ist gehoben
in denen wir nie das hauses der alltag
zurück und mit ihm christians funktion
als finanzieller unterstützer der
großfamilie noch gar nicht im kader
natürlich einfach darum sehe nicht dass
ich wirklich kann erreichen und dann
machen und danach christian reich hat
ein großes herz für die kinder des
quartiers hatte auf deren schulweg eine
kleine brücke bauen lassen
während ihm die leute hier dankbar sind
halten im jänner in der schweiz vor
er gebe unnötig und blind vor liebe sein
geld aus und was man jetzt machen dass
die schäfer zukunft ja ich hoffe machen
da man clean ist machen wir das sind
immer sehr viele sendungen und da haben
wir schon zwei fliehen
und das schöne daran green im pool
machen dass man etwas mehr aber war der
reporter
und da hab ich alle kumpels und die
herrlich eventuell machen wir dann
natürlich den ruf und die mitglieder und
david natürlich einen abschluss mit der
hörer muss damit an je mehr ich sage mir
wie die schweiz einmal fuhren immer
milch beschäftigt und da der frau vor
allem bei der familie an ihr gefühl das
hat überhaupt kann ist die echte mir das
sind dankbar und entrückte wie sich
nicht so das ich abgebe werde nicht
einmal eine franken
und dann gehts echt überzeugt
[Musik]
die anspannung bei aldiana und treten
ist verflogen
das essen hat allen geschmeckt und jetzt
obwohl der abend noch nicht alt ist jagt
die stimmung im saal dem höhepunkt zu
[Musik]
das duo orchester bringt serbische
lebensfreude in die zentralschweiz
[Musik]
am tag danach sind die herzen schwer auf
dem busbahnhof von puerto plata
christian und wären wir nie da müssen
sich voneinander verabschieden
noch immer verweigern ihr die schweizer
behörden die einreise
doch christian glaubt weiter an ein
glückliches ende ihrer liebesgeschichte
und der trennungsschmerz habe ihre liebe
ein stück weit auch gestärkt
[Musik]
21 mal abgefahren da mal nicht meinte
ich hoffe mal das gleiche leid ich habe
darauf das hättet mich
naja
spät nachts herrscht auch im saal des
casinos zug aufbruchstimmung
hier sind aber alle glücklich freut sich
einer etwa so auf die hochzeit nach dem
hotel
sie skizziert mannschaft an mir ist dass
[Gelächter]
ich von dem schweren reitunfall haus
lief und wieder singe ich muss das lied
what you tube guggenheim
und so eggert aldiana sonst redens
traumtag morgens um halb vier mit dem
auftrag der katyn an ihren ehemann er
möge ihr zuhause wäsche zum umziehen
besorgen
[Musik]
kurz war die nacht auch für christian
hilfiger vor aufregung hat er kaum
geschlafen und diese aufregung ist auch
am morgen früh nicht kleiner als er sich
für den großen tag feierlich gekleidet
wie geschlafen
[Musik]
denn sinn
von manuela hat er sich am vorabend
bereits verabschiedet sie hat bei der
trauzeugin übernachtet und hat heute
schon früh am morgen den coiffure
besucht
mit brautkleid frisur und schuhe
alles sitzt perfekt
[Musik]
endlich eine stunde vor der trauung
fährt christian zusammen mit ottmar dem
trauzeugen und dessen freundin kamen
nach merligen zur kirche
pfarrer in häggenschwil im garten der
familie buchecker deutet äußerlich nur
wenig auf die bedeutung des tages hin
heute heiratet andrea andrea ist das
nesthäkchen das jüngste von fünf kindern
der bucheckern also nicht wer zum henker
so scott ich merke grund und alles drum
und dran tragwerk schaffen und sie hat
ja normal dass der landrat
und sie weiß dass die ezb will komisch
märz war überhaupt zu einer geltung
nur eines scheint die aufregung nichts
anzuhaben
oli bärtschi verrichtet im stall sein
werk auch heute so als wäre der tag
nichts besonderes
gelassenheit ist die losung des 39
jährigen bauern zumindest nach außen
es braucht ja nicht jeder zu wissen dass
auch ein kerl wie er nervös werden
könnte da sparen und sich teilweise
gegen wen ich bestimmt sie die kirche
habe ich denke wenn dann dreht er in
normalen fahrrad und wie für den cfc im
kleid und in ohligs chf sich trauer bis
1 million so
im gegensatz zu uhr ließ und andreas
hochzeit findet die traum von manuela
und christian hilfiger bereits am
vormittag statt
es sind die letzten minuten bevor
manuela vor ihm stehen wird noch immer
weiß nicht was sie tragen wird
[Musik]
kurz vor elf ist es als auch manuela in
merligen eintrifft
[Musik]
geht es dir gut bin
er ist auch immer dann rein und dann
siehst doch wollte immer mal wieder
ja ist das gut
[Musik]
nächste woche im großen finale manuela
und christian hilfiger tauschen die
ringe
gute nachrichten für christian reich
endlich darf bin wieder in die schweiz
kommen aldiana und räten petkovic
besuchen in der flitterwoche paris die
stadt der liebe und andrea und uli
bärtschi begeben sich auf ihrer fahrt
ins glück
der schönste tag heute in einer woche
[Musik]
ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz
präsentiert von amag